I was gonna say that the whole point of what I do, the Monster Ball, the music,...
...the performance art aspect of it,...
...I wanna create a space for my fans where they can feel free and they can celebrate,...
...because I didn't fit in in high school and I felt like a freak.
So, I like to create this atmosphere for my fans...
...where they feel like they have a freak in me to hang out with.
Yeah.
And they don't feel alone.
So, that's why.
So, it isn't really for someone to talk about you.
It is not for that.
It really is to create a space for people.
Well, this is really who I am.
And it took a long time to be okay with that because, to show you all,...
...and maybe in high school, Ellen, you feel discriminated against,...
...it's like you don't fit in and you wanna be like everyone else,...
...but not really, on the inside you really wanna be like Boy George, you know.
Yeah.
Oh, I did anyway.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I really, I want my fans to know that it's okay, you know.
Sometimes in life you don't always feel like a winner,...
...but that doesn't mean that you're not a winner.
I was a rebel like you wouldn't believe.
In high school, I wore outfits that I would, I think, be considered...
...I was in Atlanta, a very small town in Texas, Atlanta, Texas...
...and I wore an outfit that was, I would be the Lady Gaga of Atlanta, Texas, I think.
Look at this crazy. I was wild.
Look at the outfit I wore.
Come on! Come on!
I was a rebel.
Well, that is shocking.
It looks great. I love it.
It's very 70s.
Well then, I wanted to see what you would,...
...I was ahead of my time because I'd put you in it, and I think you could carry it off.